nuevos ensayos de misiles que llaman la
atención según el estado mayor conjunto
surcoreano el ejército norteño lanzó dos
misiles de corto alcance en la madrugada
de este jueves algo que las resoluciones
de la onu si castigan en el caso de
corea del norte expresamos nuestra
profunda preocupación por los últimos
disparos de corea del norte de lo que
parecen ser misiles balísticos de corto
alcance en medio de los diversos
esfuerzos de nuestro gobierno por
alcanzar pronto el objetivo de la
completa desnuclearización de la
península de corea
los proyectiles llegaron en aguas del
mar de japón recorrieron una distancia
de unos 450 kilómetros y alcanzaron una
altura máxima de unos 60 kilómetros
desde este jueves es el segundo ensayo
de armas que realiza el régimen en una
semana tras probar dos misiles de
crucero el pasado domingo según expertos
esta maniobra es una señal de que
pyongyang quiere un diálogo serio con la
nueva administración estadounidense de
joe biden
cada vez que una administración llega a
washington intentan adoptar una posición
fuerte es una especie de táctica de
negociación así que creo que esperábamos
este tipo de actitudes
en el pasado de enero el líder
norcoreano kim jong-un y ya instó al
nuevo gobierno de job airén a proponer
nuevas alternativas para poder retomar
pronto las conversaciones sobre la
desnuclearización al país empobrecido y
golpeado duramente por la pandemia no le
interesa un enfoque paciente sino ir
elevando la atención regional de cara a
poder sentarse cuanto antes a negociar
una retirada de sanciones